- It's nice to see you.
(audience cheering)
- Hello.
- It's good to see you.
- We did an interview
together the other day
and I don't remember your
hair looking this fabulous.
- I think it was wearing a hat, maybe.
- Oh, okay.
I don't know, I'm like,
I love the longer look.
- It's too long.
- Is it?
You're gonna cut it?
- I don't know.
- Don't do it.
- Well.
- It looks so cool.
(audience yelling)
You've got the natural curl thing going.
It's cool.
- Well, thanks.
- [Kelly] Just saying.
- I just get frustrated having
to do it in the morning.
- Says every woman on the planet, join us.
Yeah, yeah.
Did you make any resolutions for '23?
- I didn't make any resolutions.
I have a few things on my mind.
Goals and ambitions.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I feel like with the resolutions,
it's kind of like set up
for failure every time.
- Failure.
- So I just kinda approached
it with some personal goals,
some professional goals.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There's a lot on the
personal front, obviously
being a new father.
- Yeah.
- So that's taking up
most of my time.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] You're gonna try
and get sleep this year.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, I was like there's no sleep
when they're that young.
- What about you?
Did you?
- Your daughter turned one though, right?
Or she's about to turn one?
- She did.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well, over the weekend.
- [Kelly] Okay, over the
weekend she turned one, okay.
Did you throw a big party?
- We did, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Little, you know, we had to celebrate.
She went through a pretty wild journey.
- Yeah.
- In the early part of her life,
and so, we had to celebrate in style.
- Yeah.
- She's one.
She's beautiful.
It's amazing.
- She's adorable.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- The best.